okay just throw up a link to some more
of the Microsoft quantum stuff up there
none of what I'll be talking about this
on there though so we're gonna be
talking about problems in combinatorial
optimization and I want to talk about
exact optimization not approximate
optimization you're given some
commentary on optimization problem you
want to really find the optimum of it
and the the the class of problems I'll
be talking about and the algorithm could
potentially be used for a more general
class but the analysis is a little
simpler for this is so called max I need
to get a better chalk max D Lin -
sometimes max Kalyan - what are these
these are problems where you have a
bunch of variables Z sub I try and get a
better marker that's a little bit a
little bit more solid you have variable
Z sub I and each of them is gonna be
minus 1 or plus 1 and this I goes from 1
up to n so just a bunch of you know
binary variables and you have some
objective function that I'm gonna write
H sub Z and the objective function is
going to be a sum of monomials of degree
D so in the case D equals 2 for example
it would be sum sum of like some of our
I J ji j where j IJ is a matrix zi c j
so this would be the case D equals 2 in
the case D equals 3 you would have terms
zi z j zk c IC j gz k ZL for d equals 4
and so on and the j IJ would be some
weight so this may be a weighted problem
and so let me just say what's known
classically essentially nothing is known
faster than brute force as a classical
algorithm so brute force would take a
time most are meeting up to some
logarithmic factors which in this case
will be polynomials man oh starve to the
yet that's basically the fastest
classical algorithm known that works in
general for the case D equals 2 there is
a very nice algorithm due to Ryan
Williams it takes time to the Omega of n
but it takes exponential space where
Omega is the matrix multiplication
exponent I'll ignore that basically you
can't be proved forced classically so
quantumly what can you do well quantumly
of course you can do a grove research
and speed that up o2 to the Omega of n
there's there's an algorithm to takes -
to the Omega of n where Omega is the
matrix multiplication exponent just
for the case T equals two and it takes
exponential space Omega n 2 to the Omega
n so
oh sorry Omega over 3 n sorry to the
Omega over 3 X re about that sorry about
that of course that would be worse do
the Omega over 3 so yeah sorry so it's a
little bit faster and and it's to the
Omega over 300 oh really need to worry
about 2 Omega or 3 I mean takes
exponential space and it's only for the
equals 2 so for general D there's
nothing known faster than this and if
you want polynomial space there's
nothing not faster than that and that
Williams algorithm it's not known how to
quantumly speed it up also so ok so this
would be grover this would be grover 2
to the N would be classical and then
there's a 2 to the Omega and over 3/4
just for D equals 2 but let's you know
I'm just mentioning it for completeness
but don't worry about it know what
nothing is known about how to do it
quantumly and it's also an exponential
space alright so that's the best we know
yeah so showing these four does not help
no as far as I can tell I mean so the
standard form of showing is for case at
where you're trying to find something
that satisfies all the clauses and here
we're looking for Max and we're looking
for a maximum number you don't know how
many and many of them will be violated
now there is a variation of showing
which will work for this but as far as I
can tell I mean it was only studied to
how well can it approximate things which
are not exact things as far as I can
tell from putting the details of the
paper it does not give anything
non-trivial in this case either in fact
it doesn't even give a non trivial to
the end - anything interesting like
there's no to the N - little o of n
that's interesting even just doesn't as
far as I can tell but I may be wrong
that's just based on me reading a
subsequent paper after showing so this
is the best we know how to do
classically quantumly you can ask what
you know how to do quantum Li and a
natural so classically of course let me
emphasize there are lots of here's to
gathers then in practice do way faster
than this for many important instances
but that's the best provable quantumly
people have studied a heuristic the
adiabatic algorithm which would consist
of studying a family of Hamiltonians so
you would have h which would be some H
of Z well write it as SH of Z plus 1
minus s X where X is
the some of the the terms X ion each
spin it's a transverse field and you
might imagine varying this s from 0 to 1
and at s equals 0 1 minus s sorry s
equals 0 this term is the the dominant
term and you can easily prepare the
ground state as well maybe there's you
know no closing of the the gap no the
gap never becomes too small along the
path and then you could prepare the
ground state unfortunately I think the
situation is even worse for this
algorithm that is not only are there no
provable guarantees I think there's a
lot of evidence than in practice on
really generic instances it's super
exponentially slow that the gaps will
become into the minus in small super
exponentially small gaps and that's how
long it will take so I don't think you
know there it's really even useful
heuristic so so that's kind of the
situation and I want to talk about more
about why you know my interpretation as
to why it takes that long and I want to
apologize a little bit to the next big
creases I saw there's gonna be something
in there and there's there's a statement
I think in the next beakers I've tracked
that maybe one problem is that this
Hamiltonian has no sign problem or as
they say now still clastic sometimes
that so ok so there should be a minus
sign in front of here sorry if we're
gonna minimize the energy that I don't
think that's a problem at all I think
that I think the problem with the
adiabatic algorithm is I don't know if
that's what the next vigorous weeks the
next viewers just saying that that's a
common belief ok ok ok good so there's
there's there's a there's a paper by
Altschuler and company in condensed
matter
condensed matter physicist talking about
a problem with this algorithm based on
many-body localization and the idea that
they say is the problem as this they say
ok let's look let's look near you know
near s equals 1 so we've got a small
transverse field and and so the so now
you think about the boolean hypercube so
I'll just draw a small boolean hypercube
right
yes and somewhere you know here's the
ground state wave function here's the
here's the exact ground state of the of
the of the combinatorial optimization
problem we want to study and as you turn
on this transverse field the wave
functions sort of instead of being
peaked here it gets some amplitude that
spreads out across the cube of course
I'm drawing this kind of very very
loosely you know I'm only drawing three
dimensions and I've kind of draw drew it
as if the amplitude decays like in some
continuous way it's really a discrete
function but the idea is that okay so
the amplitude is like the is the the
probability is strongly concentrated for
the ground state wave function near this
op near this adir the exact solution and
it's a k's in some way away from there
and for most choices of local
interaction you can add whether it's
this particular one or other ones that
maybe have a sine problem
it'll be localized near there so if we
drew it if we sort of imagine drawing it
if instead of drawing this hypercube
which is a little harder to drew draw if
we drew the wave function is a function
of say a single degree of freedom just
imagining that this hypercube could be
written as a one-dimensional space you
know the ground state wave function will
look like this it'll have some
exponential tail and now on the other
hand far away on some other corner of
the hypercube there may be some excited
state wave function which would be a low
lying excited state and now these wave
functions are localized in completely
different parts of the hypercube and
this one might be you know almost the
same energy of this if the weights are
integer weights maybe this one at s
equals zero is only energy one above you
know it's almost as good as the ground
state and then when you add on the
transverse field it can easily happen
that at no transverse field this is the
ground state and its small transverse
field this becomes the ground state and
there's a level crossing and of course
it's actually becomes an avoided
crossing even comes a very small avoid
crossing they say well really the
problem is that there's a a localization
that you know when you add these local
perturbations to this thing the ground
state wave function for small values of
this perturbation when these when this
transverse field term is small is going
to be localized near a certain portion
of the hyper cubic and that's the
problem so I want to I want to talk
about the algorithm I'm gonna talk about
another algorithm for optimizing this
problem for doing this optimization and
the idea of this algorithm this is not
how I explained it in the paper but it's
how I'm thinking of it now so I want to
talk about now is to think about
different ways that the wave function
could be localized we have some wave
function Phi of X
yeah yeah so like the amplitude decay
exponentially with the hamming distance
away from there yeah I mean of course I
can only draw a small cube so that's why
I'm pretending it's one-dimensional but
yeah you know so yeah so if you want you
could say that this is the hamming
distance from then then it then it would
be sort of a more sensible plot yeah to
say like the hamming distance from the
origin then it decays exponentially yeah
that's a good way to talk about this
bond so there's localized than the
hamming distance but also it means that
there's one wave function here and
there's another wave function here and
this is the ground state and this is an
excited state and they have exponential
tails that just barely reach each other
so yeah they can't actually do a level
crossing but if you change the
Hamiltonian a little bit here this
energy can go right through that energy
up to some you know exponentially small
crossing and how big is that crossing
it's the ability to tunnel from here to
here you might have to tunnel a distance
of order n because it might be far apart
and because this all happens it's small
s it can happen in an S that's like
order the transverse field that's order
like 1 over N to a very small transverse
field that's how you get into the minus
n because you might have an incredibly
weak tunneling between things incredibly
far apart yeah because the same
localization I think probably goes on
there I mean so there's a there's no
proofs but there's good physics
arguments and you know so ok it may be
many it may be many it may be many yeah
I'm just don't think so
but I don't know well ok if there's only
a small number then no no you can't have
trouble with just one or two others you
just really it depends on how many
others that will dictate where the level
crossing occurs let me yeah no it
depends how many there are
depends how many spins are flippable and
so on I'm going to get into stuff
related to that so I want to get into
the idea for this algorithm so this wave
function has some norm rights i of x
squared so x will be like the position
and things might be localized in the
sense of this l2 norm that is almost all
the way to the l2 norm is concentrated
near this point on the other hand you
can imagine that if you looked it seems
like a strange thing to look at the l1
norm of the wave function that this
might be delocalized most of the way to
the l1 norm might be far from the
point even though the wave function
itself is localized near here you could
have a large a large tail and why is
this interesting well suppose we could
do some Hamiltonian not exactly this one
but we can make some weak perturbation
that got the wave function to be
delocalized in the sense of this l1 that
would mean in fact it would have a very
big l1 norm if this l1 was delocalized
and this l2 was localized in the norma
this is you know some of this is clearly
equal to 1 so if this guy is delocalized
then the sum of this might be much
bigger than 1 and what is this quantity
well if the wave function is all
positive if the wave function is
positive everywhere
if psy of X is greater than n equal to 0
everywhere then this is actually just
the inner product of the wave function
with the state that I'll call sy plus
that's the maximally polar SD the state
where everybody's polarized in the in
the in the transverse direction up to
there's like a 2 to the n over 2 factor
in front so sy + let's say sy plus is
plus 2 the tensor product and everybody
maximally polarized so it just has the
same amplitude on every site and so
there's a 2 to the minus n over 2 in the
normalization so if you take this inner
product you get there so if we can get
this thing delocalized into l1 norm and
get a large l1 norm that means we can
get a large inner product with this
state significantly larger perhaps than
the 2 to the minus n over 2 and then
that gives us an idea for a quantum
algorithm the idea for quantum algorithm
when we first think about it in Reverse
in Reverse is which of course we can't
do but then we'll run it forwards
prepare the state in the exact ground
state of course we don't know what the
ground state is do some tweak to the
Hamiltonian so that we get to some state
which is delocalized and has a large
inner product with sy plus then measure
sy + and you'll succeed with the
probability much bigger than to the
minus n over 2 much bigger than to the -
I'm sorry I probably much bear them to
the minus sign so that then inspires the
quantum algorithm of 1 prepare sy plus 2
now evolve and I'll explain it more
evolve a short path and what do I mean
by a short path what I mean is we're
going to start with a hamiltonian whose
ground state is not sy plus it's ground
state is going to be this this ground
state here that's almost this localized
one but not quite
from from that delocalized one - what -
just completely hfz
so I'm gonna call it from each of one -
H of zero where I'm changing notation
now H of s is kind of H of zero is going
to be H of Z - H of zero and H of one is
going to be something else I'll explain
it's gonna be a little perturbation of H
of Z so you're going to evolve from here
to here and then measure in Z basis
measure and you know see if you succeed
and so if you didn't have this evolution
here this evolution here if you just
prepared sy + and measured in Z the
probability that you get the correct
ground state would be probability 2 to
the minus n over 2 so this thing would
succeed 2 to the minus n of that's or
sorry probability would be 2 minus n the
amplitude B to the minus n over 2
probability of success would be to the
minus n and so then you could apply
standard amplitude amplification
basically just doing Grover's search and
turn it up into a time 2 to the N over 2
algorithm to find the ground state
that's not very interesting that's just
grow for search again but if we can make
this so it has a larger amplitude we can
speed up so we'll take a time to the N
over 2 is Grover and we'll have a
speed-up a speed-up that depends upon
depends upon a certain overlap and it
will depend upon this overlap here it
will depend upon an overlap between a
certain ground States i1 which let's say
psy 0 comma 1 it's the ground zero for
the ground state and want to indicate
that it's for this Hamiltonian h1 and
the state plus
whether we can create a large a large
amplitude a large inner product between
these two states we're not starting in
across a there's going to be actually
three distinct differences one is we're
not starting in the ground state so
that's sort of the short path thing
that's that we're not starting the
ground state the second one is we're not
going to do this Hamilton we're going to
do a different Hamiltonian this is gonna
be a different Hamiltonian and the third
one is that we're gonna actually need to
do this evolution to ridiculous accuracy
and I'll explain how we do that later
like the evolution here needs to be done
to exponential precision but that can
fortunately be done in
polynomial-time yeah yeah so so what I
what I want to do is I want to have
something that if you just adiabatic Li
a vowel slowly changing the Hamiltonian
you have to worry about like the error
you know when you run it on a quantum
computer so fortunately because this
will be a very small change in the
Hamiltonian it will be possible to do
this up to some error that's
exponentially small an end using
existing quantum simulation techniques
in phase estimation so I'll skip that
but we'll just it take it as granted
that we do need to do a very accurate
evolution here and you can do it
quantize it and get a classical
algorithm that be due to the yet that
was a good question I mean I thought
about that similarly I don't know how
and my suspicion is no that really this
is this is to be very like heuristic
this is actually a use of having a
Hamiltonian with no sign problem that
you can get constructive interference
from all the different things that
happen to create this large l1 inner
product that essentially what's going to
happen when I analyze the head that the
study that the the problem I'm gonna get
some random walk which looks very
classical but I get to add all the
amplitudes in a constructive way so I
don't think so but maybe well it is
under an assumption on the density of
states you need an assumption but it's a
fairly loose assumption ok so this is
the algorithm yeah with the ground state
of this perturbed Hamiltonian that I
haven't yet to find
if I prepare up side bus and I do faces
the mission and measuring that actually
that's exactly okay good question three
that's exactly in fact how you wind up
doing it to do this to very high
accuracy because it will turn out it's
sort of funny this ground state of this
h1 will actually be very close to the
ground state of h0 so in fact all you
need to do to evolve is you actually
when you cut it down to its simplest you
prepare this you phase estimate this
Hamiltonian measure that that's actually
all you need to do because these these
two states are almost the same but the
idea is even though they're almost the
same like maybe there's like a you know
a small angle between them like 45
degree angle between them their
difference is enough to greatly increase
the amplitude of this state in the side
plus direction so that's the so yes
actually the the full gallery yet can be
simplified to just prepare phase
estimate done and that's how you and
then you do the phase estimation to very
high accuracy using ability to estimate
exponential per se you know estimate
exponential accuracy probably miss
estimating using a polynomial number of
measurements so now I need to talk about
what Hamiltonian we do so now I need to
talk about what Hamilton we do so the
whole thing is just about yet coming up
with a Hamiltonian that whose ground
state is very close to that one but has
a large overlap with the side plus so
what is the Hamiltonian gonna choose so
here's an eraser okay so I'm gonna get a
so I'm gonna lightly change the family
so it's going to be H of s is going to
be this H of Z minus s so s is this
parameter we're just going to do s
equals 0 or 1 times B which is a
strength a strength of a field B is
positive times x over N to the K where K
is an integer exponent ok and so we're
gonna choose these two quantities B and
K and what we need to guarantee there's
going to be a small change in the
Hamiltonian from here and here we don't
want there to be a level crossing now if
there is no level crossing which we'll
discuss later and this can happen then
you get a runtime that is going to be o
star of 2 to the N over 2 that's the
Grover thing times X peers your speed-up
of - that'd be over 2
k/n where little B is sorry the notation
gets kind of unwieldy and I have not
been able to simplify it that the
notation is little B is big B over the
ground state energy so basically the
bigger you can make this the more
speed-up you get on the other hand when
you make this power K bigger the less
speed up you get so depends upon how big
you can tweak these terms and you tweak
them in such a way that it still runs
but that you don't have a certain bad
thing involving level-crossing happen
but we can give some guarantees under
which that level crossing doesn't happen
much stronger guarantees so it just it's
a speed-up that oh and D is that order
of whatever we're doing max deal into
the details don't matter it's the
speed-up that depends upon these two
parameters I mean the details do matter
but don't get caught up in them at the
moment how do we pick them yeah we'll
get to what those probably that why
these parameters are important they're
just you know their parameters this we
have you can kind of look at it and see
that if K got really large if K was of
order n then this term is basically zero
except when NB X becomes of order n so
it's basically just a just a term that
projects onto the polarized the
maximally polarized state if K gets too
large so it becomes uninteresting when K
gets too large this term though the
bigger we make it sort of the more
effect this transverse field is able to
have so this is the kind of Hamiltonian
we study so I just want to discuss you
know I don't have too much time so I
want to discuss - I get to you one
second two things one is how long shows
this cuz this relates to this
interesting random walk thing and then
what are the guarantees under which you
show this you know how do we you know
what assumptions do we have under H of Z
such that this happens because we can
give specific statements about the
density of states H sees such that if
those hold then this will happen so yeah
question so X is X is sum over I X I
over N okay so it's just that n is the
number of spins it's just a
normalization it's just this a nice way
to normalize it K is like three it's an
integer it's an integer the bigger K is
you know the less guarantee of a
speed-up you get the less speed up you
get but the
fewer assumptions you need to get that
speed up the weaker the assumptions
under what you can show that speed-up
are so they're their parameters you pick
this right here
how does it depend on the grass stain
energy you right there vo equals largely
over epsilon T grounded right yeah we're
gonna get to that we're gonna get to
that we're gonna get to it so let me how
do you how do you show this speed up
first assuming a certain thing holds how
would you show this speed up well I want
to analyze the ground state of this
Hamiltonian at s equals 1 I want to
analyze this ground state and there's a
really nice perturbation Theory called
I'm gonna mispronounce the French but
Brillon Vigna perturbation theory so
this is this is a really beautiful tool
invented by Donna figner for for
studying perturbation theory of
Hamilton's and most people you know
you've probably seen if you have a
Hamiltonian that's a sum of two terms
and one is a perturbation to the other
series for writing down the eigenstates
of the perturbed Hamiltonian and they
usually if you do Rayleigh Schrodinger
which is the usual series you'll see
they get hideously complicated after the
second-order you know everyone knows the
first order perturbation theory everyone
knows the second where it's like the
square of the matrix element divided by
the energy difference and then nobody
knows the third except for people do it
specially because it just gets
ridiculously complicated brilliant
figner just stays nice at all orders
it's a very very nice way of doing it
now in this talk I'm going to assume a
unique ground state for H of Z the paper
did a unique ground state I have a
manuscript in preparation that removes
that assumption but for simplicity I
will not do that we'll just assume a
unique ground state but you can remove
that assumption okay so you have some
Hamiltonian H sub Z plus some
perturbation V and you want to study the
ground state the eigenstates of this so
what you do is you write down and let's
put an S in front so s is like a
strength of perturbation you're going to
define the ground state as in a series
of this so of course and we're gonna
write the ground state as Phi rather
than sy and the reason is that I'm gonna
save sy for things that are normalized
to have norm 1 and Phi is gonna be
normalized a little bit differently Phi
is going to be the ground state of this
but normalized so that its inner product
with the original state is 1 but it's
norm itself will be bigger than 1
okay so what is Phi so if I well to
zeroth-order is just sigh right so -
next order I'm probably gonna get all
the signs wrong here but you know you
can check the paper for the signs so the
next order you have something that's
like a sum over let me let me let me let
me let me say that H sub Z has
eigenstates I you you will index
different eigenstates with energy energy
EU so size zero will be the ground state
of H sub H of Z psy 1 psy - psy 3 will
just be excited States with different
energies so I'll be so so sci-fi will be
size 0 plus the sum over you not equal
to 0 s v sy u over u minus e nan and I
probably have to sign wrong there I
think it's probably - so that's the same
as the usual first-order perturbation
theory right perturbation theory you
know matrix element - excited state
divided by an energy difference next
daughter plus sum over U and V both not
the ground state s squared
oh sorry what I this V is sorry let me
fix that up sy u times the matrix
element sy u V so the matrix element
from the ground state to an excited
state
and then you put the ground state and
the excited state in there will be a sum
of s squared sy u / e u minus e0 e v- e
0 and then sy u v and so on this one
stays simple in all orders so every
order in the perturbation series has the
ground state and then matrix element - 1
excited state or 1 excited state to the
next excited state at third order will
be size 0 to savvy savvy to say sy 0 to
say V sy w sy w Desai you and so on a
sequence of energy denominators that's
it
except let me just correct it this C 0
is not the ground state energy this is
I'll write it as e 0 comma 1 it's the
ground state energy of the perturbed
problem that's what makes the
perturbation Theory ridiculously simpler
if you keep this as the ground state
energy of the unperturbed
which is the usual way that the
perturbation series is expressed and you
try to normalize the state to one then
beyond this order everything gets very
complicated but if you make this the
energy of the perturbed problem and you
normalize it this way then it just stays
simple at all orders and you can analyze
this series pretty nicely because what
happens is when this V is this x over N
to the K X over N to the K just takes K
random spins and flips them you can flip
the same spin twice that is to the
ground be exact
know this yes the exact energy of the
perturbed problem if you try to expand
this in powers of s then you can get a
you know full if you expand a 0 comma 1
in powers of s then you can get us a
series where everything is just
expressed but this is the exact energy
of the perturbed problem so that's a
weird perturbation series you know at s
equals 1 this is correct so let me just
in general put a 0 comma s so this will
be this will then hold for any s that
it's defined self consistently so now I
start with the ground state this just
flips right K random spins and gives me
an excited state this says take the
ground state flip K random spins flip
another K random spins get an excited
state and so on and so on and so on so
what I get is a sum of states all these
states are going to come in with
positive coefficients so I can easily
compute their inner product with the
size because they're in a product with
the size is just this matrix element you
know the inner product of all these
state states with sy plus is just to the
minus n over 2 independent which state
it is so I can easily compute the inner
product of the state with sy plus the
only tricky thing is to compute this
energy denominator but there's a nice
thing that if you take the initial state
that has energy e naught and this is one
of you two that's the question how can
the complexity depend on you know take
an initial state that has energy e
naught flip K random spins the energy
will typically go from e naught to e
naught times like 1 minus K over N
because you flipped a certain fraction
actually DK over N because D spins can
appear in h1 and so you can estimate
that this changes by this energy
difference is really not times K over n
then you get it twice now you might
worry oh these are correlated random
variables you know this is a random
random walk you're randomly walking and
measuring a product of energy of energy
differences but actually this is a
simple calculation that
doesn't matter how they're correlated
that this energy did that you can
effectively take this first energy
difference and substitute K over N and
this substitute K over N and two K over
N because you flipped it flipped it
twice K over N two K over N three K over
N for the third order and so on so it's
it's just a nice little fact about
random variables doesn't matter how
they're Carolee that when you compute
this inverse of products you get that
and so you're gonna get some series when
you want to compute its overlap with the
ground state when you want to compute
its overlap with sy+ so then all these
things become to the N over to where
this becomes like K over N this becomes
K over N and to K over N and then next
early at K over N to K over N and three
K over N and if you look at you realize
that looks a lot like the series
expansion of an exponential because you
have this powers of s in the numerator
you have powers of K over N to the
denominator and you get 1 1 times 2 1
times 2 times 3 so you get a factorial
in the denominator so you reach some at
all and you get that speed-up over there
so this gets to Scott's question like
how does the speedo come there all these
paths but somehow they all
constructively give a contribution to
the overlap so that's why it's that I
think is how the algorithm works so the
last thing I'll mention yell ok under
what circumstances can we show this one
can we show that this works we can show
that this works as long as you know
there's a few assumptions for this for
this series to the series is always
convergent in fact if this if this graph
state energy is put in as the ground
state energy but you need to show that
the ground state energy didn't shift too
much that the e 0 comma 1 is actually
still pretty close to e 0 and didn't
change too much and you also need to
show to do that second step of phase
estimation in the algorithm like start
with the state and phase us to make the
chair in a ground state you need to
grant a gap to stay open to measure that
you're in a ground state so you need a
gap of some Hamiltonian to stay open you
need that when I add this weak
perturbation to it that really the
initial hamiltonian I was assuming
initially we had a unique crowd state so
I had a gap of 1 between the ground
state and the first excited state as I
said you that can be removed but for
simplicity let's keep that on then when
you add this small perturbation the
energy changed only a little bit that
the gap stayed close to water and here
what we should think is okay can we make
a state of this hamiltonian that's got
you know initially Tamil
had some energy e not and then a whole
bunch of states with energy e naught
plus one and then more excited states at
higher energy so on this was we want to
ask when we had this perturbation on
what happens to this gap how much can
this gap change and in order for this
gap to change it has to be the case that
looking just in the subspace spanned
perpendicular to e naught we can find
some state that has an expectation value
for this Hamiltonian with energy close
to e naught right so we want to ask can
this gap can this gap close can it be
the case that we turn on s then suddenly
oh you know there's actually a whole
bunch of states down there that one of
these states came down from here in
order for that to happen it has to be
the case that if we look at this
Hamiltonian projected into the space
orthogonal to e naught that you can get
a state with energy close to e naught so
you have to be able to get an
expectation value of this term that's
close to 1 you have to be able to get
some state that has some state sy Oh see
some state C such that expectation be x
over n to the K is like of order 1 or
say 1/2 you know has to be at least some
constant and also expectation Hz of the
state C isn't too big either you have to
have a state you have to be able to form
some state that has a large enough
expectation value for this guy to
compensate the fact that it's made out
of excited States for that guy and this
is where the high power of K comes in
because the only way you may worry that
you know this is an expectation of a
power of K for simplicity there's
technical steps to get around it imagine
we were just thinking about taking the
expectation value outside of the power
this is this is this is the [ __ ] with
the ability for the algorithm to succeed
and this gets down to like how many
perturb states you need for it to see
well the Lord Joe would norm came from
this perturbation series so this is to
show that the perturbation series works
and to show that we can successfully
measure whether in the ground states as
I see it they're two distinct things
that the large l1 norm came from this
series well so I'm summing up this
series and when I sum up this series to
get the inner product every single one
of these terms contribute some constant
right some some quantity that's
independent of what this final state U
is I can just replace this sy you with
to the minus n over 2 and then I sum it
up and the question is like can I get a
large contribution from the how are
terms of the series if so then I get a
large yes yes that's where it tries to
take advantage of it that there's no
side problem right so now I think that's
actually a good thing here that's
actually a good thing because it's like
there's many trajectories and they're
all interfering constructively and how
would you I mean write the whole art of
a quantum algorithms to make many
trajectories somehow I'll do the same
thing useful and here and so there's one
way to do it I mean there's a lot of
ways to do it but one way to do is to
make every kid's trajectory have the
same sign well I mean so of course that
doesn't say anything against that
because we're only going for a speed-up
that's you know from 2 to the N to 2 to
the end so I'm some lower exponent right
so you know if you go from or 2 to the N
over to 2 to the N over 2 times some
lower X 1 so if you're able to speed up
that doesn't imply that there couldn't
be a further polynomial classical
speed-up we're going at best for a
polynomial speed-up over grover at best
so so it wouldn't you could sample all
this but I mean most optimistically I
mean it's not even clear whether you
could efficiently sample it and I think
you really gain from the interference
but most optimistically when you sample
it you still would have a polynomial
slowdown in your sampling which then is
no contradiction because this is only
going for a polynomial speed up for what
setting of these parameters do you get
the largest speed
but were the best known classical
algorithm well as I said any setting is
a speed-up over the classical because
the fastest cost gravis - yeah okay so
well so that's why I want to get to
what's the what's the what conditions
can we put on these parameters and I
guess the last thing I'll talk about
loksabha Levitan quality so in order for
the thing to fail there has to basically
be some when we when we turn on this
perturbation the gap between the ground
state in the excited state has to become
small essentially so that we can no
longer phase estimate which state were
in that's when the problem arises but in
order for that to happen there has to be
some you know state formed that of
excited States that has energy close to
what the ground state energy is so it
has to be gaining in energy from this
term because it paid a price here now so
that means it has a large expectation
value for this term now technically it's
a large expectation value for a power of
K just to simplify some of the technical
steps let's pretend that it's really
that if you take the expectation value
of x over n it's a large expectation
value for the K power of that will
change the power of the expectation
value the K power for the K power of the
expectation there are technical steps to
get around that we'll just pretend that
so if K is 3 say say K is 3 then if X is
you know square root of n if the
expectation value of x in the wave
function is a square root of n which is
actually quite a polarized state yeah
it's got a pretty strong polarization
then this would be like a 1 over N to
the three-halves thing so and so even if
B is polynomial a big B could be as big
as in to the three-halves so that
depends upon how big the ground state
energy is and this term would still give
only a small contribution so you need to
have actually states with a very large
expectation value of x in order to get a
large expectation value this and the
bigger the K is the bigger I can make
that expectation value of x used to be
you know if K is 100 then even if the
state has an expectation value of x
that's like into the 98 over 100 this
still gives only a fairly small
contribution that needs to really start
having about kontrick powers of X that
are almost fully polarized X very close
to 1 and so there's a nice inequality
there's a whole literature of this
inequality called log Sobel of
inequality and the funny thing is when I
tried to read it at first I heard what I
talked about the comforts about this
years ago and I didn't understand
anything
but I realize it actually means
something very simple in quantum
mechanical terms the type form of the
log Sobel F inequality
is this is this you take a state's eye
that's a pure state and someone tells
you you have two tasks you are given a
fixed X polarization of that state okay
and you want to minimize its entropy
when its measured in the computational
basis how do you do this you know
someone says okay it should have an
expectation value of this capital X
that's exactly equal to DA and I want to
have as little entropy as possible in
the X basis how do you do it first fix
expectation value of x just the
expectation value of X is fixed the
total expectation value of X is fixed
and you want to minimize its entropy in
the computational basis how do you do it
the answer is and this is the log so
eleven equality when put in these terms
is write down a product state where
every qubit is so polarized somewhere in
the XZ plane in such a way that each you
know that the total X polarization is
right so when each qubit is fully
polarized in the X direction then and
that's the tight answer when each qubit
is fully polarized in the X direction
then the entropy in the computational
basis is maximum as you start to make
each plug Q but get more polarized into
the Z direction in less than X direction
you get less X entropy but more Z
entropy and this gives a relation then
between a large x expectation value and
a large entropy of the state so the only
way you can start to generate these
states is if you have also an enormous
number of low lying States so you can
make it such that if I pick K to be like
99 which would still beat a classical
algorithm the only way it would fail is
if there is something like there there
are states that are very highly
polarized like into the 98 over 99
polarized which would mean that there's
sort of two to the two to the end to the
98 over 99 states with energy within
like a constant of the ground state so
not just like one or two states down
there but in enormous number and you can
tune how many are in there see
okay so as far as I know yeah I mean
I've been trying to study the classical
literature to learn more about this
there are some second paper coming out
there's some obvious classical speed ups
you can do when you have huge numbers of
low-lying States as far as I can tell
these give you more in the cases where
it does but I'm not an expert on it and
so you know someone can tell me more I'd
like to know where anyway I'm pretty
much way over time now but so let me
just let me just conclude so things the
things I want to emphasize this exact
optimization is hard
classically little is very little is
known about exact algorithms but there
are very good heuristics and practice
quantumly I don't think there are good
heuristics and I think the trouble is
this localization but I think we can
kind of turn it around and we can take
advantage of these tails of the
localization and we can take advantage
of no sign problem to give a
constructive interference and get a
speed-up and so this is the whole idea
of it to get a constructive interference
and get a speed-up from tails of the
wavefunction when you only slightly
change the Hamiltonian the gap doesn't
close and there's really three ideas in
the algorithm one idea is short path you
only you don't try and follow a large
path you just try and perturb a little
bit around it you need to very
accurately follow the ground state
evolution using this high accuracy phase
estimation is to retask and you use this
power of x over n2 which which which
which which allows you to prove some
results and similarly in the analysis of
it there's really two key ideas in the
analysis one idea is this bill on figner
perturbation theory which allows you to
express it in terms of random walk and
makes clear why having no sign problem
can be an advantage because you can get
a summing up of all these terms in this
series and this log so blending quality
which gives you a way of understanding
that well the only way this algorithm
fails and so you can express it in terms
of a theorem that either this Iram finds
the ground state in this time or the
problem has this number of states with
this energy at most that and you can
make those guarantees look rather
extravagant in terms of it must have an
enormous number of low-lying states with
energy it was this and yeah I would be
very interested to learn more about
what's known classically so let me let
me stop you
for the questions
so hope you studied isn't needed for
specific problems like this right so
there's exactly one case in this whole
talk where I use that it was max dealin
- okay one case which is that when you
analyze these energy denominators you
say that well if you have a max dealing
to instance and you flip some randomly
chosen fraction of the variables you can
estimate how the entered average energy
changes you can say that if I flip K of
the variables the expectation value the
energy after flipping them is is is if I
have a city with a given energy
afterwards it's like 1 minus K over N of
that energy or actually 1 minus DK over
a more general problems that can change
in much more dramatic ways but maybe
some other guarantee can be made so
somehow there's something about the
landscape of this max deal into that if
there is a minimum I mean any algorithm
that tries to get a speed-up has to
assume that the landscape of this Hz is
not like a golf course there's not that
HD is completely flat except there's one
answer somewhere so you have to exploit
something about it and somehow this max
deal in two has one useful thing which
is that if you start at low energy and
you flip a bunch of variables the energy
doesn't change too much in some way and
and you can control much better how that
happens then for other problems I mean
of course there will still be some
guarantees as to how the energy changes
but I don't know
as strong ones so that's that's where
it's used but yeah I could analyze it
for others
no matter what you will get a pretty
good solution yes yes yes okay okay good
yeah a good question so I have something
about that in my paper that yeah you can
make a hybrid algorithm you can say you
know we we run this algorithm and at the
same time we also just just run a
straightforward Grove research to try
and find a low-lying state and you can
then make some some statements about
either you find an exact solution in
this time or within this time you find a
solution of this quality and again you
know as far as I can tell I don't see a
classical one that's as good and the two
things that I saw our one is in back to
the question about Shana Graham there's
a modification of showings algorithm to
deal with finding approximate solutions
and I didn't see anything getting is
quite as good and there's some other
work hybrid algorithms for certain
problems of this form but and depends
what kind of solution you're going for
in certain regimes they do better when
you're asking for like pretty good
approximate solutions but when you start
asking about oh you know I want a
solution that's within you know energy
one of the ground state or energy two of
the ground state where the ground state
energy might be in or into the three
halves or N squared or something
then I don't see a classical one as good
but again I'm not an expert in that
field I mean it's just what I can
repeats together
okay here's a good question yeah I mean
you may ask like well if this fails I
mean it does still give you a state and
it will give you a state that's that's a
good question I'm not sure I mean one
thing that's interesting is if it fails
it will identify a state that's sort of
like this that's one thing you can do is
is you could run it and sometimes you
could go measure in the Z basis and get
your state but sometimes if you felt
like you could run it and measure in the
X basis just for fun and you'll see like
oh these are the spins that got
polarized and so what I've been thinking
is that that may mean that you can
identify you know a large basin of
flippable spins like oh this you know
this this this fraction of spins which
is actually some enormous fraction of
the total number of spins by the way you
could take like K to be log in and that
would give an algorithm that's still to
the N but it's to the N might or to the
N over 2 minus n over log N and I don't
know how to do that classically either
then it would require that in fact not
only are there that there's like half
the spins are flippable so you could you
could get something which we identify oh
yeah actually here's a solution where
these spins are fixed and all these ones
can essentially be chosen at random and
you still get a very low energy state
and we'll find you that basin so I don't
know what you know yeah exactly what
that's useful for but I've been yeah I
have so I have something in preparation
which extract some sort of fairly simple
stuff from it but I expect that more can
be extracted that you may be able to say
that
yeah problems where this fails like
really you can pin down a lot about the
state I don't know that's a good
question all right I'm forgetting this
on off the top of my head I have two
different things I could tell you in
terms of two different problems one is
you can look at I ran a completely
random choice of this H sub Z where the
variables are chosen plus minus 1 and
you just look at the case D equals 2 you
could also look at higher D 2 if the
weights are chosen Gaussian a lot is
known about that problem in fact there's
even rigorous results on what the
typical density of states is and then
yeah you can get
in additional speed up and I don't off
the top of my head know exactly what the
numbers I'll be but let's just say
roughly you'll be in the ballpark from
maybe going quadratic to cubic or
something around there speed up or
across and then another fun toy problem
you can study and again I don't know
what the number are I just ran this one
on my laptop for fun you can ask
yourself I mean this is all regime in
which you can prove things and you can
ask yourself well yet could I push it
even a little further about the law
energy density
you could take the equals one so it's
just a linear function and just polarize
all the spins in the Z direction for H
sub Z and study that toy problem it's
just all the spins are polarized and you
get some some other polynomial speed-up
in it I mean it's obvious you should get
a polynomial speed-up because you can
you can do that one with the adiabatic
but you might want to just ask well how
much can we do in this case and there is
a limit to how much you can do if K has
chosen bigger than one because you do
encounter certain level cars but you get
some other pond again I don't remember
what that polynomial is but I intend to
yeah yeah yeah I mean I just analyzed
one case but I would hope that maybe
there's some more oh sorry when you said
black box I thought you meant that it's
a sort of a family violence we can plug
in better HC no because I use something
very specific about HD they sound very
specific which is that when which is
that if you flip a bunch of random spins
the energy can't change too much
it's yeah but if that didn't hold there
would be no way to say that this thing
was large
so so let me put it this way okay
we analyze this this term here okay so
we have some initial energy that's anat
of the ground state okay so I'll be some
large energy that we can get some very
large you know that's the ground state
energy when you do this first flip you
taking the ground state and you flipping
K over end of the spins some very small
fraction so you have to be left with an
energy close to the ground state so this
energy denominator can't be too big
because it's only the fraction of spins
that you flip that enter in there but if
you had totally a black box this energy
denominator could be as big as a naught
it can be much much bigger and that's
that's the difference that's that's how
it enters that's I mean you're really
exploiting the fact this this this
energy denominator difference is exactly
where what enters in is that the
landscape of this problem is not a golf
course it's a you know it's got some
cones or something some
[Applause]